explíquenos cómo se sentirá este aumento
de la tasa de interés de la reserva
federal
bueno estamos viendo a subidas en
intereses que todos consumidores usamos
no por ejemplo a la deuda que la gente
sacan para comprar casas se ha notado
que ha afectado ese mercado porque se ha
bajado la cantidad de deuda que se está
sacando pero ese interés afecta a muchas
de las cosas que la del consumidor
normal a tienen acceso para pagar su día
a día para vivir y uno de los grandes
miedos es que esta política monetaria
agresiva pueda generar una recesión
económica en eeuu usted cree que esto
podría suceder
sí claro es extremadamente una realidad
y hay mucha gente que ya hay muchos
economistas y políticos que ya están
hablando de ese tema
la realidad es que estamos en una
economía no sólo aquí en eeuu el
premundial que es una economía de
burbuja que se ha inflado por la
política del centro del banco central de
eeuu y el banco central de muchos países
a estos niveles de intereses son
históricamente artificial bajó y el
nivel que lo ha subido el feder ahora
históricamente no es mucho y si miramos
la última vez que la inflación estaba
así de alta
estamos hablando hace 40 años y era un
nivel que
en los niveles de interés es que el pp
tuvo que llegar para poder calmar esa
inflación fueron 12 por ciento ahora
mismo estamos hablando de un interés de
1% y medio no es nada comparada mente
así que en una economía basada en deuda
un interés alto obviamente va a tener
una influencia muy muy negativa y
precisamente usted habla de que la
subida no ha sido tan alta como en otras
ocasiones y a propósito la fed ha sido
criticada porque en un inicio defendió
que la inflación sería pasajera y ahora
quedó claro que no cree que la fed actuó
tarde ante la inflación
sí claro actúe extremamente tarde y no
está actuando muy agresivamente tampoco
históricamente hay una economista que
aquí dice que el stadium aunque está en
cargo de los pérez está hablando como
paul volcker que era que estaba en cargo
del feder en los 80s pero en realidad
está actuando como ben bernanke que
estaba en cargo de como el 2008 2007 y
como alan greenspan que fue que infló la
burbuja de la economía aquí en el
principio en el 2000 en los 2000 es y
después bernanke y lo siguió exacta así
que así y tarde y no suficiente